[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
May 2nd I'm Dion rabone for the Wall
Street Journal filling in for J.R Whalen
new data show that over the last six
months cancellations have outpaced new
subscriptions for digital memberships
but getting out of the subscription
cycle may not be as painful as you think
and joining me is Nicole Newman personal
Tech columnist for the Wall Street
Journal Nicole you've written a guide to
pushing back against subscription price
creep so let's define that what is
subscription price creep I've been
getting a lot of emails lately about
digital subscriptions that are going up
most recently Strava which is a fitness
tracking app doesn't mean email saying
my subscription was going up from 59 a
year to 80 and I think that if you
subscribe to a streaming service you've
probably gotten emails with this kind of
subscription price creep it's a price
that adjusts a little bit every year and
it doesn't seem like it's a dramatic
increase but over several years and
because of the recurring nature of these
costs they can really rack up and why do
we need to push push back against that
because we can and also because a lot of
people who sign up for subscriptions
aren't sometimes aware that they're
still subscribed to a thing and also
there's a lot of friction built into
unsubscribing from a lot of these
recurring costs so the most important
thing to do is actually make sure you're
using the stuff that you're paying for
I think everybody probably has a story
like yours right where they were
surprised with some news as you say in
the beginning of your article from the
company why are we seeing so much
subscription price creep on the content
side for streaming services the cost of
content is going up because labor costs
and economic pressures even companies
like Strava which is a fitness tracking
app their costs are going up to for a
lot of other Digital Services they maybe
haven't raised their prices in a really
long time and are deciding to now there
are various reasons why and It All Leads
to us paying a little bit more for these
kinds of services you've got a five-step
guide to pushing back though but rather
than ask you what the five steps are
I'll ask you why you felt it was
important to write a step-by-step guide
in the first place I think that our
digital lives are inundated by
subscriptions my planned app for example
has a pro version that allows you to pay
199 a month for advanced plant tips
these kinds of recurring costs are
absolutely everywhere and especially
hidden in places like app stores and so
if you can every month or every quarter
evaluate the subscriptions that you're
still paying for see if there are
freebies that are good alternatives for
stuff you're paying for you can save a
lot of money in the long run they're
also great apps that can automatically
comb your financial statements and find
recurring costs for you one app I really
like is called Rocket money and it did a
fantastic job of finding a few
subscriptions that I would rather I
didn't know I didn't remember that I had
and I unsubscribed right away so thank
you rocket money and mint also does this
but I found that rocket money does it a
little bit better you have to be okay
with handing over your financial
credentials to the third party service
that market money uses to integrate your
bank statements and such you know the
fact that there are entire apps or
companies based on helping consumers get
away from these things gets to it being
so hard for consumers to get away from
or get out of these subscription
services that in some cases can end up
eating all of our paychecks why is that
so difficult yes and in fact rocket
money has a bill negotiation service and
I talked to a co-founder of Rocket money
who gave me fantastic tips on the type
of bills that you can negotiate and
those are your bills for cell service
cable internet home security and
satellite radio he said that these
industries have such a high customer
equity decision cost that calling and
even threatening to cancel may get you a
better rate and oftentimes sell service
companies for example will roll out a
new plan offering more data at a Deeper
Discount and won't roll over old
customers to that new plan so just
calling and making sure you're getting
the best rate is an easy way to lower
your bills what was the most surprising
thing you found in your reporting for
this story how hard it was to find the
cancel button in most places and also
that the cancel button sometimes
triggered a better rate for that service
instead of just letting you go they'll
say well do you want to stay on for just
two dollars a month instead of 18 and
that was an easy yes for me so I stayed
with some Services even though I had
intended to cancel when you were
reporting this story you talked to a
subscription pricing consultant who
works for companies like Microsoft and
Netflix she said that a lot of
businesses count on opt and I thought
that was fascinating what did she mean
by that and how does that optimism work
to the benefit of companies more than
consumers a lot of times
she talked a lot about aspirational
subscriptions so in my life that would
be Duolingo the foreign language app
there are subscriptions like language
learning or Fitness that if you
unsubscribe it feels like you're giving
up on your progress towards a language
learning or Fitness goal and those
subscriptions can be the most dangerous
because we're unwilling to cancel them
was there anything you learned in
reporting out this article that you've
already applied to your own life did you
get a lower price on that fitness app
well I got a lower price on certain
subscriptions but I also used my library
card to get a lot of fantastic benefits
so there are some great free
alternatives to streaming services for
example Libby which is available for a
lot of public library card holders in
the U.S has in fantastic Academy
award-winning movies and great
critically acclaimed TV shows so I
definitely recommend you check it out
with your public local library card and
also there are some great software
freebies a Libra office for example is
an alternative to Microsoft Microsoft
365 now has a pretty hefty subscription
or you can switch to something as simple
as Google Docs sheets or slides and on
the fitness side there's a lot of
fantastic content on YouTube but you
have to be willing to sit through an ad
or two and spend more time hunting down
that quality content all right that was
wsj personal Tech columnist Nicole
Newman thanks for being with us and
that's your money briefing I'm Dion
rabone for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]